it is time of course for the press
preview our first look at the front
pages
as they arrive over the remainder of
they are we'll be taking a look at
what's making the headlines with matthew
science columnist at the sunday times
and christina patterson journalist and
author
but first let's take you through the
front pages that we have some of them
may be a little bit delayed because of
the football
but here's the sunday telegraph it's
reporting at the prime minister's
wedding to his fiance in a secret
ceremony at westminster cathedral early
today
saying that even close aids were kept in
the dark
a lab leak in wuhan is a feasible cause
of the global covert pandemic according
to british intelligence sources quoted
in the sunday times they also report at
the prime ministerial wedding
pointing out he is the first serving pm
to get married
in 199 years
writing in the observer the labour
leader keir starmer claims that the
prime minister's bocces
could delay plans to lift covert
restrictions in june
as mentioned we're joined by matthew
side and christina patterson
lovely to see you both again it has been
a little while um so christina let's
let's start with you shall we in the
front page of the observer we just
mentioned it in the paper stack there
a secure starmer is warning that things
might not be going according entirely
according to the roadmap and there's one
person that he's blaming for that
yes well no great surprise that he's
blaming boris johnson
as indeed uh did boris johnson's number
one man
or until recently number one man um
this week dominic cummings in seven
hours of testimony
to various select committees
i must say this indian variant is it's
very very
worrying and it does feel like deja vu
all over again
in that it seems to have been the case
that the government actually knew about
the indian variant and how dangerous it
was or at least how infectious it was in
very early april but it was at least
two weeks it was two weeks before they
announced that they would make
india a red country and then they had
hundreds of flights pouring in from
india in the days before they actually
implemented that so this does feel
it feels very depressing we've all
waited so long
to have any kind of taste of normality
again
and a number of scientists including one
as you've been mentioning on your news
bulletins who was
very influential in um introducing the
first lockdown last year after his
mathematical modeling
showed how dangerous it would be to not
lock down
has said we need to be careful the
scientists are kind of a number of them
are sounding a lot of alarm bells so
i i just hope that boris johnson on this
occasion will err on a side of caution
at the moment most of us can do plenty
of things we couldn't do before we can
see friends inside we can go to
restaurants we can go to cafes
we can go to pubs we can go to bars i
think businesses need to be supported
for a few extra weeks until
more of the adult population has had two
vaccines because two vaccines are
necessary to protect against the indian
variant
and then let's just hope and pray that
that gets us through this because
it's been so long now and i think we're
all desperate to get out of it
yeah matthew i i suppose it would take a
degree of political will for the prime
minister to
to to delay the the road map as he set
out i mean events around
at the westfield shopping center in
london today that protest march that
march for freedom shows
there's not necessarily a majority of
people who want everything to open up
back now but there are certainly a
sizable number of people who want him to
stick to the plan
well in an ideal world we all want him
to stick to the plan
providing it doesn't lead to an
exponential increase in
in cases which you know given the
data we've seen in recent days seems to
be likely as as tim gows has said
um i think for all it's worth i think
the majority of the population is very
cautious
uh about kovid i mean you're right there
are people who are
anti-we're all anti-lockdown the
question is whether we do it early in a
timely fashion
and therefore can keep some of the
economy open or whether we
wait too long and therefore have to shut
down harder and for longer with a higher
number
of excess deaths but but i think the
instinct of of a
large number of people in this country
almost from the beginning
has been pretty cautious notwithstanding
occasional demonstrations so i
i think the uh sensible political
decision for johnson is
is something that he hasn't done
terribly well so far which is take the
the medium-term view christina take us
to the sunday telegraph
um i mean the headline kind of points
you in the correct direction for the
story fresh questions
for matt hancock over over care homes
one suspects those questions are related
to testing or the lack thereof of people
being moved
into care homes yeah well it's been a
very bad week for
matt hancock but not nearly as bad as
for the relatives of all those who died
in care homes
i think we we knew already that people
were released from hospitals into care
homes without being tested and then that
caused
vast numbers of infections and vast
numbers of deaths
there's no surprise there it was tragic
but no surprise because we knew that
already
being very hard to know the precise
numbers because in those early months
the testing
wasn't available i think the key issue
here
is as dominic cummings said you know not
always known as a warrior for justice
truth and honesty but on this occasion
i felt that a lot of what he said had
the ring of truth
and i presume he has some documentation
to back some of these allegations
up he seems to have been very clear that
matt
hancock promised that people would not
be released from hospitals into care
homes without being tested
but more and more evidence seems to be
emerging
that the guidance did not mention
testing in fact instructed people to be
released from hospitals into care homes
without testing and all in spite of
protests from people uh in the care home
community and the people sort of at the
head of that community
those saying that this would be unsafe
their protests were ignored so this does
look like
mass killing basically obviously i'm not
suggesting matt hancock
intended that and he's worked
unbelievably hard during the pandemic as
most people in government have done
but to have lied about something like
that even in a government that lies
fairly regularly does seem
pretty serious i mean matthew's as
christina said there
not saying that he intended people to
die but the question is whether or not
he was reckless
as to the possibility and i've
interviewed government ministers
countless times
over the past nine ten you know 14
months and every time this issue came up
that mantra
a protective ring was thrown around care
homes was thrown back in my face
well i agree i agree with christina that
uh
dominick cummings a lot of his testimony
was for me anyway
came through is highly credible that the
one thing that made me slightly hesitant
is the way that he
attacked certain people who he clearly
doesn't like very much like
matt hancock and the prime minister and
was extremely generous to those he does
like
like sir patrick valance and rishi sunet
so so in the case of hancock i would say
i'd like to hear
his side of the story he did i mean he's
i think a bit slippery
um and i don't think he was completely
candid in his press conference or in his
statement of the house of commons
but i would just say that we had a
limited supply of tests
um it was an unprecedented time in in
march
2020 i mean there were so many things
happening at the same time so many
strands of evidence
and argument impinging upon decision
makers cummings describes it as complete
chaos
and i can just about imagine uh
depending on
when we hear the other side of the story
that a fair-minded person would say that
that hancock and his decision-making
team were swamped and this was not
negligence but just a front-line
professional
juggling contradictory concerns in real
time i don't know
what the answer will ultimately be but i
wouldn't condemn hancock on the base
just on the basis of matthew we need to
we need an inquiry sometime soon um
christina
let's let's move ourselves on to the the
story in the front of the sunday times
their lead story and this this
this will be alarming an awful lot of
people uh british intelligence sources
telling the sunday times that there has
perhaps been a chinese cover-up
and that the wuhan lab leak theory is
feasible yes i mean they're not saying
it's
likely or that it's the most likely
explanation they are literally just
saying that it's feasible
i do think opinion seems to be shifting
on this but we simply don't know
at the moment the who were not given
proper access not very surprisingly
uh in order to when they made their
investigation and they concluded
the lab theory wasn't very likely i must
say last year
i tended to the view as a
covert obsessive obviously i tended to
the view that uh it that the lab
theory and landscape theory was kind of
conspiracy theory territory but
actually after reading and reviewing the
sunday times insight team's
book about the government's handling of
kovid
and the potential origins of the virus
i i changed my mind i mean you know who
am i
i have no idea but it does seem that
it's not at all impossible that that's
the case because the bats
are where the coronaviruses breed are
thousands of miles away and there
doesn't seem to be a very plausible
route for the virus to reap
to have traveled from the caves where
the bats are
to an animal whether it's a pangolin or
whatever in that wet market so we don't
know but i think at this point we can't
dismiss
anything out of hand the trouble is i
don't know whether we ever will know
because clearly the chinese government
are not going to be candid about this
matthew what do you think well i think
it's a very important empirical question
if china
have covered this up then i think it has
big also strategic implications i mean
we're in the midst
i think of effectively a cold war ii
china have tried to project
its diplomatic financial and other
muscle around the world one belt one
road
uh wolf warrior diplomacy uh maneuvers
in the south china sea
and if it turns out that they have done
this i think it will be a pr
disaster of seismic consequence
and give america which has suffered
globally
under trump an opportunity to reset the
agenda and try and shape the world
around a rules-based system and against
a
increasingly totalitarian chinese
communist party so so you know i think
it's important in its own right
but has broader implications uh as well
welcome back to the press preview with
me matthew and christina taking you
through the papers
uh matthew let's let's come to you this
time um two stories to go and
guess what you're going to be the
wedding or the football you want to talk
about yeah it's a football it's the
football
good result for chelsea pretty pretty
bad end to the season for manchester
city
yeah like well for sure but guardiola
pep guardiola the manager of manchester
city fantastic manager tactically
such an innovator but i think he got the
tactical plan
wrong uh chelsea were outstanding they
were great in the tech
they set up with superb organization
uh they deserved to win but can i just
pick out one player who i think
is a is a stone cold genius and that's
in golo kante
who is the chelsea defensive midfielder
he's tough
man of the match they tackled his vision
his intelligence on the pitch he was the
unsung hero for leicester
uh winning the premier league world cup
with france what an amazing
beautiful player christina your views uh
on the contributions of n'golo kante in
the champions league final
well i would love to elaborate and i
hate to perpetuate stereotypes but
all i can say is that i haven't seen my
bloke all evening but i did hear some
whoops of delight at one point from
another room so that's my
only contribution to the subject at hand
i'm afraid
matthew just just one quick word from
you though it was really really good
to see thousands of people enjoying
themselves
and getting into the stadium it does
feel like in terms of sporting events
we're getting a little bit back to
normal
wonderful sports i i know not everyone
is into sport but as
an ex-professional sports person it's a
joy to see
it's a key part of our culture for many
of us a key part of life
and the the other thing by the way
talking about football in southwest
london
brentford the team of my father-in-law
uh got promoted to the premier league
today beating swansea in the
championship playoff final that was
another
great uh great contest so it's it's
wonderful to have
sport back yeah just down the road from
where i'm broadcasting from in fact so
i've decided that i have been a lifelong
fan of brentford at this very evening um
christina something we can all agree on
who doesn't love a good wedding tell us
about
the one that's on the front of the times
well at downing street have not even
confirmed that this wedding's taken
place but today
apparently allegedly boris johnson
married his fiancee carrie simons
in a wedding that has been planned for
six months but kept top secret
and perhaps more surprisingly at
westminster cathedral
who knew that a twice divorced man could
get married so easily
in the country's catholic cathedral but
anyway he did
and allegedly it was a very happy
occasion and she wore
a beautiful white dress and they gazed
each other adoringly as you should at
weddings and
red vows don't know exactly what he said
in his vows maybe
better luck this time anyway good luck
to them um
i'm glad if they had a happy day um
not enough happiness around at the
moment so there we are
i i think you have to get permission
from the bishop but that would be an
that would be an ecumenical matter i
mean matthew i mean i think the one
thing we can perhaps say
didn't one of those stories recently
that he was planning on having his
wedding at checkers
next year and paying for it you're not
telling me that everything i read in the
papers isn't correct are you
yeah i saw that story i mean i've got to
say christina's
good wishes were the most most
crutchingly expressed i think i've ever
seen
but i you know i i know christina has
great doubts about bryce johnson as a
primary i have doubts about boris
johnson's prime minister but
i do genuinely hope he's he's very happy
and and carried too i think you know i'm
i'm very pleased for them
um well on that on that bombshell
matthew christina we will see
you again for more of the papers at half
past 11 for now
thanks very much indeed